if this happens I will straight up lose
my mind in a good way
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so Firefly is the greatest TV show ever
made it had 14 episodes of just
brilliance
there's perfect
I love it
I have had to just do a video talking
about Nathan feeling wanting to come
back to do Firefly as potentially a
series of TV movies with universal and
Warner Brothers
and as part of that conversation about
those chats about maybe bringing the
Firefly back I got told this little bit
of information
and I ran round and I did a home alone
impression
um I got very excited so what is the
piece of information
the Nathan Fillion wants to bring Alan
Tudyk back to the Firefly franchise as
well
now
if you watched Firefly and particularly
the movie Serenity you might have
spotted the problem with this plan
there's a subtle flaw
wash is dead
I know hoburn wash
like a leaf on the Wind
got impaled in a massive Spike and he's
100 percent
dead so how could they bring Alan tudik
back to a new Firefly series
well
I've no bloody clue and I don't actually
care because Nathan feeling and Alan
tutic are just excellent very very good
friends they
um a lot do lots and lots of interviews
together they're always missing about
they're always playing pranks on each
other I mean it does seem that everybody
from the Firefly franchise became really
good friends and they were like a family
and I think that's one of the reasons
why Firefly was so popular even that's
how difficult I'm saying Firefly so many
times if I'm flare flare it keeps going
like flam plan and when flam flam to
come back
um but Firefly
they were a family and I think that like
came through on the screen
um that you know like dual stay and
everybody they just really really got on
Simon doesn't have to come back I'm not
bothered about that but I want everyone
else to come back and if Alan Tudy could
come back even if it was just for one
episode I would absolutely love it now I
actually think that Hoban Washburn
the little ginger fella himself was
probably my favorite character in
Firefly
you've always thought that they should
do it that um Zoe Washburn his wife was
pregnant at the end of firefly that but
we didn't know that obviously and that
her child is maybe the new pilot of the
serenity in whatever new series or TV
move it looks like
um we then get I think that's a very
sensible very logical way of doing it
I don't see how Alan tudik comes back
unless they just ignore the fact that
he's dead
can they do that you can just ignore it
to be honest
I I I'm torn because on one hand I think
God no you can't you can't just
completely ignore Canon it comes
completely ignore the movie like it
didn't happen but on the other hand we'd
get Alan dudik back
so one night I go screw it just just
ignore it just bring it back on the
other hand I think that even if they
just did one episode where say Mal's
injured
and he's hallucinating you know a bit
like out of gas or something like that
and he sees
Alan you know he sees wash and washes
talking to him and you know helps him to
survive whatever it is that's going on
even if even if that was it I could live
with it oh God bring him back as a ghost
or an Android I don't actually care
that's the that's the thing about
certain characters that you just love so
much that you know they get brought back
all that Kirk died loads of times
um and they keep bringing him back
so yeah why not just bring him back for
the TV movie the fans would go crazy
we'd love it Nathan feeling it love it
because it's like his best friend and
you know I think Alan tudik would love
it because you know
he's Alan tudik
so why not
um
I love the resident alien TV series and
that can go on forever and ever as far
as I'm concerned I love that um actually
Nathan Fillion has done the voice he did
the voice for the octopus in the series
of Resident alien and actually Alan
Tudyk has appeared in the rookie he also
appeared in Castle
so
you know they work together all the time
and they work together brilliantly
I I'm going on a little bit in this
video
basically because I am so stupidly
excited by this possibility but I do
have to then unfortunately
bring in a little bit of reality
this is just a conversation now
apparently this is even not Nathan
Fillion that's brought this up that
there are Executives at Universal that
have been having conversations with
people about this possibility and it's
got to go very much firmly into rumor
possibility of doing a straight to TV
movie with Warner Brothers in
partnership with Warner Brothers
um for Firefly so a firefly movie and if
it does well maybe a couple of firefly
movies
I have even heard the rumor that the
conversation about an animated movie
with the actors voicing all the parts is
also a possibility but I've heard that
that's not really what Nathan Fillion
wants to do it was just sort of like
raised
how both of it animated okay we'll do
live action
um so I think live action is far more
likely but at this point it's
conversation so they're going to raise
different possibilities so my
understanding is that it's very early on
in the even not development it or could
we
so that it's actually Executives at
Universal that have raised this
possibility that they would actually
love Alan Tudy to come back and they
think that that would just make for an
even better show it's just how do you do
it I can't see anything feeling disagree
as long as the story made sense and I
can't see anyone else disagree
so
this is one for you guys though it's a
rumor let's not get too excited about it
just yet until he's actually on screen I
would give this 50 50 at best
I actually think the project getting
made at all is 50 50 at best
um so let's see what the next few months
brings
but if it is possible
and if they do genuinely come up with a
good idea for why he can come back would
you actually care what that idea was if
it meant that we got washed back on the
serenity
because I personally wouldn't and I hate
prequels and I hate it when they sort of
bring people back or they do time travel
episodes to it activism I hate those
things if an actor and this you know a
character dies he should stay damn dead
I hate it when they recast characters
we're on our third Kirk fourth Kirk
third Kirk we just don't need it
but for this character
I actually wouldn't care as long as Alan
tudik played him I genuinely wouldn't
but guys you tell me what you think get
in the comments
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where you get to see
most of our new videos first and you get
to see them without the adverts and in
most of those videos I won't waffle on
like a child because I'm so over excited
by the possibility
promise
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
foreign